Well she did. This was the fucked up thing
was she wasn't in any way overweight.
Like she was beautiful. She had great
body. She just, it was just like a weird,
she was an actress, you know,
and I think that that pressure,
the pressure, that Gig is
just so crazy. It's just,
first of all, you take
someone who, most of the time,
the reason why that we want to become an
actor is because they didn't get enough
attention.
That's a lot of what causes it.
Especially if you have like this weird
sort of nonspecific desire for fame.
It's not like you,
you're a really good character actress.
You know you're a Faye Dunaway
or something like that.
You just really good at,
you love the craft of creating a
character. Now there's a lot of them,
they just want to be famous.
And why? Why is that?
It's usually there's something
fucked up from childhood.
Usually somebody wasn't paying
attention to them. Parents split up,
something went wrong. Right? Yeah. See,
take this person that's super insecure
and has is exorbitant need for attention,
and then you put them through
this audition process.
The additional process is
the craziest thing ever.
It devastates people's self esteem because
you just get rejected all the time,
rejected all the,
and you're not selling a tee shirt
that know want you're selling yourself.
Did I state this girl when I first
moved to La and when she would go on
auditions when if she would get rejected,
she would want to fuck like a wild animal.
It's like she wanted
something to just like,
she wanted to just fucking scream too.
She wanted to,
she was w it was like the stress of it
all was so crazy. She wanted validation.
She wants to blow off steam.
It was just the stress of it all.
It's so unhealthy and the people that
go into that are some of the most the
least,
it's the least advisable career path
for them to be. How exactly? Yeah.
It attracts the wrong people.
It's just a fucked up situation.
You have these people judging you like
come on in Kyle. Yeah, I can't tell it.
Tell us about yourself.
A lot of trouble auditioning.
Tell me what your favorite animal is.
Who you are. I told them, you
told Tom he loved it a level.
That's great. Wow. Tom Cruise. I
want to audition once and this girl
told me, she asked me where I was from
and I said I was from New Jersey. And uh,
she goes, uh, she goes, I'm
from New York. She goes, well,
I'm actually from New Jersey, but I don't
tell people that. I go, why? She goes,
well, it's cool to say you're from New
York. I go, that's ridiculous. I go,
that doesn't make any sense at
all. I go, why would you lie? I go,
and then he just told me and she goes,
are you ready to audition?
I'm like, okay. So she's like
giving me like the sour look.
And I had a same with the
audition, told you gay. And then I,
she had a sour look on her face and
I had to sing a line from a Bruce
Springsteen song to her in the audition.
It was so humiliating.
Auditioning for Tara band movie,
some terrible movie.
It was a singing in the movie where
there's a guy and a girl and you know,
like Tom to grow.
How much a lover and I'm
singing like fucking born to
run or something like that.
I don't even remember.
I think everyone would love to
hear a little bit right now.
Ooh, can dream. I don't remember.
I don't even remember what song
didn't get it. No, no, no, not,
not only did I not get it, but this
is very, very important moment for me.
I left and um, I realized that's
when I realized I was like this,
this whole process for me at least
is broken. Like I'm not good at this.
This is not like I'm not good
at pretending to be someone.
Like everybody who goes in there,
they,
they go into these auditions and there
was these people who were like air quotes,
working actors. They do little
s I, you know, I was on,
just shoot me for saying, you know, I
had a nice episode on this. You know,
those people,
they're like hopping around those people.
They develop this real slick
way of talking and they
don't say nice to meet you
because they might already
met you. So they say, good
to see you. Good to see you.
Kyle. Good to see you. Oh
it's cause I keep remembering,
forgetting funes Dunbar's number only
serve certain number of people you can
keep in your head. But this,
this, this way of doing it.
I was recognizing it the way they would
talk. Everyone was like super left wing,
super progressive.
No one explored ideas.
You just adopted whatever everybody else
was going with and ran with. Oh yes,
I agree. Hillary is so much more
qualified ever. He would just be blue,
just say shit like that.
It was just,
it was really strange that were
like real obvious Democrat Lien.
They weren't thinking it through.
They just adopted this mindset and they
were just sneaking their way through
this system.
They were like exploiting
little personality holes in
the system and they would
get,
become friends with casting agents.
And one of the casting agents was a woman
I knew this one casting agent who was
friends with a friend of mine and she
was kind of gross and just being nice and
being kind by saying Kinda.
And uh, she fucked it.
All these actor guys and she would go,
I want to know who this is.
I can't tell you. She, she, she's a
nice lady. She just looked, she's,
she was basically doing what a lot, she
was doing the casting couch in reverse.
Right. But she was like aggressive,
sexually aggressive with guys.
Yeah.
And one of my friends,
she's super sexually aggressive with one
of my friends is a Henrietta Weinstein.
I can't tell you.
Well she,
you know,
she was,
she was casting quite a few
different shows and she knew how to,
she knew how to get these,
these, these exploit people,
these guys that were saying
good to see you. Those guys,
she would fuck those guys. Cause that
was, that was the way they could play it.
You know,
that's the way they get close to this.
Her seduction went,
I don't know when it was. It's brutal
though. Auditioning and it's hard.
I'm terrible. I booked one,
I've gotten like sketch shows,
but I've only booked one show
where it was like a script. A Guy,
it was a sitcom I booked like I guest
starring thing and I went in and I'm a
terrible reader and for the read through
they do a read through with a network.
Like I don't, a couple days before
they shoot and they gave me like,
oh you have eight new lines, whatever.
And I can, I read like a third grader,
very poor.
So I the Big Table read through it and
I stammered through the whole thing.
I got fired. So the only show I booked
really off. It's typical audition,
reading a script. I was fired
from Jesus Christ. I mean,
so many wasted hours memorizing,
paying,
acting coach and none of it
worked out for me is why?
Cause I get really nervous.
I feel very judged.
I feel very uncomfortable.
I'm a terrible reader.
So I ended up like having to memorize it
and then most of my time is like trying
to remember. It's just
basically get too nervous. Sir.
Did you ever try to like see a
hypnotist or anything like that or
no, but that probably would have been a
good idea because it was a mental, yeah.
Shutdown. Like, you know, some
people just react. You don't,
can't help how you react. But
it's like, if you can imagine,
if you're afraid of bees for example,
it's like go in and audition with a bunch
of bees flying around. You did your,
your,
your body's reacting and like a fear way.
It's really hard to grab your facilities
to act or whatever you're doing.
It's possible.
Yeah. So, yeah, no, I get it. I mean,
especially if you think like this,
God, this could be it.
This is the big moment.
Always one of the worst ways
for you to behave like or,
or to perform rather in something
that's like really important,
especially with an acting
situation where you know,
you're supposed to pretend to be in love
or to pretend to be happy and whatever
the fuck it is. Like you're, all you're
thinking is don't fuck this up. Don't,
don't fuck this up. And that's like the
overlying mantra to all your thoughts
doing it.
Do this correct is not the great mindset.
Were you going to do a good
performance? I like, um, uh,
oh,
I just fell out of my head
whenever I was about to say
I was going to be hilarious.
It was the best part of the show.
It was going to be great. Yeah,
that, but this is one of the reasons why
so many people are so crazy out here.
It's like come here crazy.
And then the system gets some crazier.
And then you also realize that unless
you're doing something like what you're
doing or are you just doing
your own thing on Instagram,
somebody has to pick you to work.
You have to get picked,
which is just nuts.
Like as comics,
all we have to do is just go to an open
mic night practice, you know? Right.
Come up with some jokes, do well you
come back, do well, you come back,
you just keep grinding.
A couple of years down the road,
you're starting to get like a
Gig here and a gig there. Yeah.
I'm opening up for this guy and yeah,
I got a Gig Mc and at this place and then
a couple of years after that middling.
And then a couple of like, there's a,
there's an actual thing you can do.
If you're good, you can
do, you can make a living.
I can't imagine just just being an actor.
Oh, forget it. Ah, they go crazy, dude. I,
I have friends that are just actors.
They go crazy.
They all go crazy.
By the time they're in their forties
they're out of their fucking mind.
And Women, oh, the,
that they feel like they feel like they
have this little tiny ass hourglass and
it's just run a sand every
day. Yeah. And like you said,
it's, you know, a lot of times you're not
starting with the most secure people. No.
Almost never.